Music can really set a mood - a little classical
or jazz might relax your whole body, while
pop or rock music can get your blood pumping
for a night out on the town. But if music
can seemingly enhance a mindset, or help you
resist mental fatigue, can it also affect
athletic performance?
The term 'synchronous music' refers to uptempo
songs with a strong beat that coincide with
the repetitive movements of a sport. And it's
this type of music that leads to a higher
work output in athletes, particularly in sports
that involve endurance with rhythmic or repetitive
movements, such as cross country skiing. This
was put into practice as Haile Gebrselassie
famously synchronised his running stride to
the rhythmical pop song "Scatman" when breaking
the 10,000m world record.
Studies show that music can act as both a
cognitive and physical stimulant, especially
when the music has a personal meaning to the
individual. For athletes who suffer from pre-competition
anxiety, music can be used to enhance mood,
self-esteem and confidence. Even during competition,
music can narrow an athlete's attention, diverting
focus away from sensations of fatigue.
In studies of athletes using music, those
who listened to pop songs during training
or warm ups had higher heart rates, and increased
muscle power compared to those who trained
without music. Furthermore, because music
can trigger emotion, it was documented to
enhance mental imagery - a technique in which
athletes picture themselves mastering a sport
before competition. This state of mind is
crucial for all athletes, particularly before
major events. Funny enough, coaches even withhold
music from athletes sometimes, as a motivational
tool. Athletes are told they can use music
during training sessions, only once they have
reached a specific productivity level.
So which music works best? Almost all findings
found that listening to music - period - regardless
of composition or speed, enhanced performance
compared to no music. However, music with
an upbeat tempo of greater than 120 bpm, yielded
the greatest improvements.
Science says, make a pump up playlist full
of your favourite upbeat songs of the time,
and blast the competition away.
Don't forget: we have a new video out every day during the Olympics. Can't wait?
Our amazing partners at the CBC already have five of the videos up now for you to binge on.
Just head to cbc.ca/Olympics/ScienceSays to watch them before anyone else. Link in the description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the hashtag ScienceSays and let us know your burning Olympic questions.
And subscribe for more awesome science videos.